économie encore avec le grand jour pour
anne sophie pic à 37 ans elle devient la
seule femme distinguée par trois étoiles
dans la nouvelle édition du guide
michelin c'est une affaire de famille
son père et son grand-père avait déjà
obtenu la récompense suprême à valence
marie-pierre samitier patrick desmulie
lorsque la nouvelle est confirmée ce
matin à 7 heures l'émotion est intense
on a tout seul on est tous arrivé ces
résultats en sont qui est ce que vous
aidiez seddik toi bien évidemment mon
père vers l'histoire de la famille pique
c'est une grande saga avec des bonheurs
et des malheurs
l'arrière grand mère sophie était déjà
aux fourneaux en 1889
puis il lui andré son fils qui gagne à
trois macarons en 1934 mais la maison
périclite les étoiles s'envole et c'est
jacques le fils d'andré le père d'anne
sophie qui repart à zéro pour atteindre
la gloire et il récupère donc la
troisième étoile dans ce sont 13 j'ai 4
ans et pan j'applique meurt en 1993
anne sophie reprend peu après en cuisine
c'est l'affrontement la fluette jeune
femme doit s'imposer aux fourneaux dans
un univers d'hommes c'est oui c'était
difficile oui oui mais bon je crois
qu'il fallait en passer par là pour
arriver là où on est aujourd'hui je
crois que la victoire elle est deux fois
plus belle parce que ça a été fait est
difficile au début
le foie gras rôti et ses ravioles de
betteraves jus aux épices douces elles à
tout réinventer en véritable autodidacte
fallait qu'elle se démarque de la
cuisine que faisait son père et ça a été
au prix d'un très gros
investissement personnel elle est la
quatrième femme à avoir obtenu les trois
macarons depuis la création du guide
michelin en 1900 en douze ans la jeune
femme a fait de la vieille maison pique
un fard de la gastronomie française